I think you and I have something in
common okay
worse both sexually highly charged and
we both once lived in Williamsburg
Brooklyn it's not true
I would I lived in Williamsburg a long
time ago I was a writer Unser net live
on I lived in Williamsburg Brooklyn this
is back when it's kind of got hipper
after I was there this was it was not a
hip place to live become like the
hipster nation yeah I was shot several
times when I lived there I was always
shocked walking over the Williamsburg
Bridge there was I said shot again I
took him in the shoulder I'm fine you
said you were shocked usually I never
walked over the Williamsburg Bridge
no that was kind of my hmm used to walk
across the Williamsburg Bridge yeah go
to the Williamsburg Bridge all the way
up to Union Square oh don't turn around
sure come back there's a nice little
hike uh urban hike oh okay
so you would do that you would walk
across I would and there was you know
what's I don't know if I can say this
but there was a guy that what could you
not say there was a guy that would sit
at like the kind of the middle of the
bridge we I mean I got to know him quite
well just I mean not really quite well
but after I say this I'm gonna retract
what I just said but um he was always
just kind of yanking his junk into a hat
or a basket
and it was always like I'm just walking
doing my thing and then all this and
it's like oh okay
and then you continued to take the walk
day after day after day and that's what
I do now on the show changing it up for
you
you take these walks across them it was
morning time I mean you know just that's
how he oh yeah the birds are tweeting
the Sun is coming up beautiful and then
ha guy with his hat okay so uh and and
do you miss it
do you miss Williamsburg
there are a few things that I seem to
encounter in my life often these things
happen around you yeah well I now I go
hiking in Griffith Park and there is
another gentleman who decides to toss
off into some random same guy
very weird this has been maybe the most
fascinating night I've had in a while
and I have to look at that I have to see
the transcript of this show afterwards
because I don't know quite what's
happened Griffith Park you say yeah got
a time for that good God
happy endings
[Music]
I couldn't have planned that if I had
sinks here